hey guys we just watched the latest
trailer for Pokemon detective Pikachu
and just like many fans we're cautiously
optimistic we thought it would be fun to
compare this new film to the original
anime fans have been quick to point out
a few pretty major differences between
the two here's what we know about the
movie so far Harry
faked somebody else's death that last
one doesn't work Pokemon detective
Pikachu is a story that begins with a
missing persons case private
investigator Harry Goodman mysteriously
goes missing
Harry's 21 year old son Tim decides to
look for his dad and find out what
happened on his quest to find his father
Tim acquires an unlikely partner
detective Pikachu this little yellow
spark plug is a wisecracking gumshoe who
normally can't communicate with humans
it seems that Tim is the only human who
can understand him this unlikely duo
joins forces to solve the mystery of the
missing pie they sniff out clues through
the neon-lit streets of rhyme city an
electric modern metropolis where humans
and pokémon coexist they come across
various different Pokemon characters and
uncover an astonishing plot that puts
the future of the whole Pokemon universe
in jeopardy sounds pretty exciting right
Pokemon fans are holding their breath to
see if this film honors the characters
they know and love or if it's doomed to
be a disaster there are some notable
differences between the upcoming
live-action in the anime cartoon that
started in the late 90s for one the
beloved character Ash Ketchum is not
going to be in the film this surprised
fans because Ash has been the face of
the series for over two decades he's the
star of many animated features but
Pokemon detective Pikachu was from a
franchise spin-off game in the game
players solve mysteries with a talking
Pikachu this seems like an interesting
premise for a live-action film with CGI
animated characters but why no ash film
director rob letterman commented on the
decision saying that the Pokemon company
has already made many many movies with
ash the company came to legendary
entertainment with the idea of using a
new character Rob said that when he was
pitched the character detective Pikachu
he fell in love with the story behind
the character he said the story was
something with a lot of
heart and that it was very unique Rob
added that because there's already been
so much work done with ash he thought it
was a really good idea to try something
new with a different character for the
first live-action movie he did say that
he still wanted to base it in the
Pokemon universe meaning it still
follows all the rules that means we get
to see a lot of our favorite things from
the Polka verse Rob's not wrong about
how often Ash's story has been told so
doing a film without him might be a
refreshing change for Pokemon fans and
there are a lot of other characters to
choose from
so hopefully this film will convey the
heart of the story that Rob fell in love
with
even without ash these are just choices
another round extra shot another thing
that has fans cautiously curious is the
fact that Pikachu talks in the film
previously our beloved character could
only say pika Pikachu but the new
trailers clearly demonstrate that his
vocabulary has expanded quite a bit and
not only does he talk but he also has
the voice of Ryan Reynolds
that means Pikachu shares a voice with
Deadpool that makes for a pretty
interesting mesh of worlds apparently
before Ryan Reynolds was cast to voice
the new role there were rumors
circulating that a few other celebs were
being considered to play Pikachu
namely Danny DeVito and the rock but
according to director Rob Letterman
run-outs had a special quality that made
him perfect to play this little yellow
guy Letterman said there was something
delightful about Ryan's big personality
and voice and he liked the idea of
containing it all in this small package
he added that while it sounds like a
mismatch it's really organic and
downright hilarious another way that the
detective Pikachu movie is different
from the original anime cartoon is the
live-action CGI animation combo in the
original cartoon there's a distinct
style with which everyone is very
familiar and comfortable ash is a human
kid but is still drawn as a cartoon the
film takes a big leap from that universe
where actual humans are interacting with
Pokemon characters Rob Letterman said
that the Pokemon characters are
incredibly real and similar to Marvel's
guardians of the galaxy character Rocket
Raccoon it's as if he is real
their letterman boasts that the effects
in detective pikachu are some of the
most high-end visual effects in the
world he added that the film is
completely photorealistic causing
viewers to believe that though pokemons
are alive and in the movie there are
mixed feelings about this photo
realistic spin on the fan favorite
characters from the cartoons an article
in The Guardian said that the
natural-looking fur and skin on the
Pokemon characters is really creeping
people out the article said not only is
Pikachu hairy but Charizard is a scaly
dragon and mr. mime who was already the
stuff of nightmares now has a weird
plasticky face on top of that they said
that Jigglypuff looks like a fuzz ball
with a curl of human looking hair
another notable difference between the
Pokemon characters and detective Pikachu
is that the film is taking a bit of a
departure from the franchise and opting
to stick with the plotline from the
detective game that means Pokemon
characters will be doing a whole lot
more than the whole battle and capture
stuff from the trailer we can see that
detective Pikachu is going to have to
rely on his keen eye in cleverness
rather than his battle skills let's just
say that fans are approaching this new
film with cautious optimism so what do
you guys think about this upcoming movie
sound off in the comments section below
give this video a big thumbs up if
you're excited to watch detective
Pikachu and be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to stay in the
loop thanks for watching the thing and
catch you next time
[Music]